- What is this movie
again, what's it called?
(fun jazzy music)
- (humming) It's called Ally.
- Okay.
Is the driver supposed to be bad?
- I don't know, Babe.
- Why are they speaking French?
- I don't know.
- Wait, so why is he not going with her?!
- Okay, you realize that I'm watching this
at the same time that you are?!
- Yeah.
- So why would I know that?!
- (laughing) I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Is she gonna kill him?
- Nope! Nope!
(whooshing)
(creaking)
- Wait, why did she just
hide all that stuff?
- Because she's secretly a clown.
- (laughing) You're not
being serious, are you?
- No!
- Oh.
- Just watch the movie!
No!
- (laughing) I'm sorry.
- What made you think that
there would be a clown?!
- Wait, but for real, though.
- No, but for real, you
need to, like, stop talking.
- Wait, just hold on!
But for real, though, do you
get a sense that she's bad?
What's your take on it?
(snoring)
- Cor, we are 30 minutes in!
No, we are 30 minutes in!
- I don't, I was asleep
for like two minutes.
I just--
- I am not watching another
Brad Pitt movie for nothing!
This was all you--
- First off, you never leave
a Brad Pitt movie unsatisfied.
(laughing)
- Then stay awake!
(record scratch)
No, prop up!
I'm gonna take your pillow!
- No, I'm propped.
(laughing)
He's not even a character.
I mean, that's not even.
- I don't like this part.
I don't like this part.
- That's not even.
- I don't like what's happening.
Tell me when it's over.
Tell me when this scene is over.
- Okay!
How long are you gonna
do this for, exactly?
- Until this music goes away.
- The music?!
- This is someone is gonna get shot music!
Can you just tell me when it's over?
- (groaning) Yes.
- Can we fast-forward it?
- No!
- What happens?
I'm gonna Google it.
- (groaning) Oh, why?
Okay, you can't watch it
because you'll Google it?!
- Well, I wanna know who dies!
- Put your hand down!
Put your hand, just give it
a shot, put your hand down!
- He got shot!
- They're not even characters!
They're probably even computer-generated.
- They are still supposed to be people.
Something is wrong with you
that you like to watch this!
- What?! No!
- It's not me!
- No, no!
- You should open that up.
- Nope!
Put that back in.
I just got thirsty, hold on one sec.
- Oh, okay.
- Here, hold onto that.
I'm gonna be right back.
Do you want anything?
- Yeah, just a water!
- [Man] Okay!
- Thanks Babe!
- Okay, pause it now.
Pause it now, 'cause I gotta pee!
- Oh, for pee? Okay.
- [Man] Yeah, I gotta pee!
- Okay.
- [Man] Alright!
Are you hungry?
I'm a little hungry, I want a snack.
I wanna snack, pause.
(groaning) This sucks, Babe.
I'm sorry, can you pause it?
I gotta pee again.
(sighing)
I gotta pee, what do you want me to do?!
I'm sorry!
- We gotta get you a diaper.
- [Man] Oh, get me a diaper, my dick!
(laughing)
(groaning) Babe, I'm out.
I gotta go, I'm gonna get some more.
Can you pause?
- No, no,
no, no, no!
- Just pause one more time!
Just one more time, I don't
have anything to drink!
- Oh my god!
- I can't watch and not
have somethin' to drink!
- Give me the strength to not kill him.
Is he gonna kill him?
- (deep breath) I'm gonna kill you.
(laughing)
Why would I know that?!
- I don't know, maybe I missed something!
- I haven't seen it either!
- Alright, focus!
- Me focus?
- Do you think he really loves her?
(slap)
What?!
I'm wondering if he actually is into her
or not, or what are they gonna reveal!
Did you?
(deep sigh)
Okay, this is one of
those where I'm asking
questions that you don't know either.
- Yup!
- K.
(whooshing)
(creaking)